So happy of you to join us. This is the Super Family movie called, this is the most actionist movie of the century.
And I hope, well you have joined us because you are a Super Family fan if you have gotten to the eighth movie.
This movie will continue through the ninth movie, and the director is Adam Young, and the producer is Amanda Young.
Now, here is Amanda Young to give you some rules such as smoking, etc.
Headphone things on your cellphones.
You have to turn your cellphones off.
No smoking.
Um, photography.
Because there's not really any point of using cameras.
There's no, um, no yelling, no shouting.
You can get out of the theater if you do any of these things.
Yes.
And the number one thing.
No talking.
No clanking.
Yes, that is it.
No yelling, no shouting.
Um, for the first part of our movie, Stacey is coming home from, uh, the, uh, Stacey is coming home from college.
And, um, home extremely early.
And arrived for so long.
On with the greatest Super Family video ever made.
Uh, on TV last night.
It was low.
It was morning.
Who do you think you are here?
I'm a friend, you know.
Oh.
I'll call you back.
Bye-bye.
Yeah, I'll call you back.
There's no one to tell him.
Um, when I'm done doing the cake tonight, can we go to the bus?
Sure.
Yeah, last Christmas.
Let's go to the backyard together.
Well, I hope the bus here costs $15.
I woke up at 2-0-1, and then I got here at 6-30.
I woke up at 4-9-99.
Wait.
I didn't have any.
Invisible money.
I'm sorry.
Oh, yeah.
I'll have to call you back.
Wait.
We got that window installed.
I just feel like evil is up to its peak at this part of the year.
Hey, um, can I slide our curtain, please?
Yeah.
Sure.
Evil, or particularly, hide.
Oh.
Okay.
He's going to be off the hotline.
Wait.
I need some help, Stacy, uh.
Stacy, why are you throwing the stuff out of the...
Stacy.
Stacy, I'm mad at you.
Don't stop.
Will you stop now?
He has to stop.
But I know the baby Sam and baby Jessica are prepared to die.
Oh, I need...
I need him to roll a...
I need him to brush his tail and the peanut butter and make sure.
Okay.
He likes doing it, so I'm gonna let him.
Guess what?
I got these for home.
I'm hungry somebody didn't go to a EG double hockey sister heaven
Chamber how do I get off got my car? I dropped it again. I do that too. I think you're so royal
Yes, we are gonna pay for that
I heard a cat ock and he's my most one of my most powerful attacks
Take it off. That's right. So he can't move take this away
Oh wavy fingers and finally that stinger is very powerful
What's this and you to attack now we get to watch the book the Barrett fight rolling though
Well now I can't use
Let's just sit down and watch yeah, let's just sit down and watch them destroy
Isn't life wonderful?
Doing I took his heart
Took his arm off
Stirring to fight wearing off. It still didn't wear off good on him. That's what I said. Okay for you
We know it with my psychic powers done so much. I lost it. I got I'm only on my last Krona
I'm going to fire a beam at her so she's on her last Krona
But we did a lot that we did a lot of good stuff, but I still have this one
We're both on our very last Krona. We have to be very careful. How dare you I can't move very good either cannot
I have failed
Attack Cobra beam out of your mouth. You forgot your stinger. Hey, and you have one of my Krona in your shoulder
I'm lining up my Krona
What's that chair in there for?
What chair? Right there. I don't know maybe to execute people
That has the Krona way back in there. It fell off. No, it's way over in there. Oh
Let's go
Krona's standing pretty good. We command each other
We command each other. We command each other. We command each other. We command each other.
What are you doing?
Influence of her. I command you to spit hit her. I mean salivate her out
Take me out. Come here salivating. Do you want me to use my fire wheel on her? We're the same color
Spread all over the field
Shall I eat these Krona to keep them safe? As long as you spit them out when I need them. Salivate them out
Spit them out. I shall eat these Krona to keep good track of them
I shall put this mess somewhere that you can't get in
I'm going to go spit the mess up. Why take it so long?
I fixed my own neck
Organized. Just take a little rest. I don't need a wire Krona just to not battle
Yeah neither do I but I'm keeping mine in
Justing yeah, I'm gonna do that just in case just in case the Krona
I'm using my voice Krona. I'm using my voice Krona just in case. Um, they fall they fall back on
back under Makuta's influence.
Yeah, if they do, I'll throw it on the ground.
Look, it took off that little gray thing.
And then I bit it off.
Hmm, it looks like a cigar, but I don't need cigars.
They're bad for you, you know.
Cigarettes are bad for me. Don't smoke, kids.
Yeah, but even though we're women,
but if we were evil, we still gotta tell kids
do not smoke or we will attack them.
There goes that little gray thing.
Anyway, I get to bite him.
Look what you have done.
Don't attack them. They're evil now.
Huh? Good thing I kept this Kana in for emergency.
Hey, this is Makuta.
I command you to attack Mwaka.
They turned good. Attack them.
We were never evil. They turned evil.
We were never...
But we're evil. We're supposed to be attacking Mwaka
because he turned good.
That's what...
Makuta told me.
I'm not...
She put me under a Kana gun.
Shut up!
Let's just destroy them.
This is Kaal talking.
You... you are all evil.
You're fighting amongst ourselves.
The Borafah are our real enemies.
Thanks, Kaal.
How dare you talk to Kaal like that.
Yes, they are.
This is getting confusing.
I have to change everything back to normal.
Meow.
Shut your half-leaf pie.
I have failed.
I'm a piece of that.
And, um...
Train my brother, not Fett.
Use Hyper Beam.
Well, well, well.
If it isn't Makuta.
No introductions this time.
Let's just get this over with.
Gelok, unfold a while.
And get your Kana in.
Okay.
Um...
Let's go.
Get my Kana back in.
Hey!
You're supposed to take that off.
I gotta take a quick rest.
Notch.
Get off.
Serious battle.
Some more Makuta.
That's my mask.
Anything.
Shut up, pea brain.
Pea is smart.
You're dumb.
Pea or pee?
Pea.
Body mode.
Peas are not smart.
Especially a Pokemon.
This is cool.
Fire!
That's that mask.
I have failed.
I'm charging up for Fireball.
Now charging up for Fireball.
Fireball.
That's it.
You're out.
You've failed.
Any topic?
Yeah.
We don't have a name, but...
Alright.
Get out there.
Ringing again.
Too much ringing in all my life.
Oh yeah?
Just have to go to my next Kana.
You always say that.
Ready for any...
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Hey, you knocked off her mask.
Look.
Hey, they can't knock off her Kana that good.
Oh yeah!
Alright.
Stay in that mark.
Kana.
I lost it.
I only got one last, uh...
Me too, and I'm wearing it.
And if you say any secret, like, codes or something, I'll be able to understand.
Yeah, next to be defeated.
Mm-hmm.
Those bora kaita are destroying us.
Morka!
Uh, yes, Dad?
Who will be my backup?
Uh, don't worry, I've got things to do.
Gotta get it back.
Oh, Chrono!
Makuta alive!
Makuta, what is your command?
Destroy that bora kaita.
I will, Makuta.
Hi-yah!
Morka, you're not on her side.
Fire beam!
You can't reach me because I've got my shields on.
Kera!
Get that good Chrono.
I don't want him turning good.
Like gum.
Morka!
Hyper kick!
Pull the Chrono.
Okay.
I hate to do arms.
Go!
Hi-yah!
Oh, I got you a Chrono right here.
It's a spare.
No, it was just in my thingy, so it's not really fun.
It feels like I'm being torn apart bit by bit.
Oh, I'm gonna transform back into a, back into Bohrok soon.
Better get this battle done quick.
We can win this.
You take the extra Chrono.
I think you'll win.
No, no, no, no.
You must battle.
You're very good.
Oh, my shoulder.
Yeah, my shoulder's in the way.
My shoulder's falling apart.
Let me see.
Ah!
Get the extra one, hurry.
Where is it?
It fell through your chest.
Ugh.
My chest!
I feel power.
I've lost my Earth power.
I've only got rock and, I've only got stone and fire now.
Use it.
But that was my Taanok shield.
But I'm not going to.
No.
It's something, it's something.
It's something similar that will happen to the Bohrok that happened to the Toa.
Because my Chrono cannot take it anymore.
Too much juice.
Better take their weak spots out.
The Sports Center.
We are going, this is halftime for the Super Family's 8th movie, Call.
Now, we have a few announcements to make.
We are going to discuss the movie.
For our first thing, we are going to interview Stacy.
Now, here we are.
Okay.
Here we are with Stacy.
Stacy Senor.
We are going to interview her and what she thinks about the battle.
Stacy, what is your reaction on this battle?
What?
Say something.
Um.
Just, I think it's cool and, yeah.
Cool.
What about your fellow members of your family?
Why are you, do you think it's cool if they're being knocked out all the time?
Will somebody just stand up and knock the Call out of this universe?
Yeah.
Probably, one of my members.
And you are third to battle, aren't you?
Third to battle last.
Yep.
Do you have any special things you would like to say to anybody out there?
Well, to my family, good luck and make sure you win.
To make sure you win!
Alright.
Um, Bob Rickstall here.
Now, back to the Sports Center.
Just gotta tell you something.
Um.
Stacy's Magical Moments is coming up next.
Oh, no thanks.
With her deadly spoon.
Battle button.
Apple in the upper level.
Technical difficulties.
We'll take you back to the battle, but first, you must find the ninth movie because we are
out of time for this movie.
Goodbye.
Bye.